[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this woman is space spraying she is
applying a mist of insecticide that will
kill the flies and mosquitoes that it
contacts it is immediately effective but
it offers only temporary control other
flies and mosquitoes will enter the
house and the operation must be repeated
this too is space praying but on a
larger scale and out of doors here the
insecticide may be applied in either of
two forms as a mist of tiny droplets
that drift slowly downward or as a fog a
blanketing cloud that swirls through
shrubbery and between houses
in considering outdoor space spraying it
is important to realize that the
majority of flies and mosquitoes remain
within 25 feet of the ground this might
be termed the insect zone and it is this
region that must be treated to achieve
maximum killed mist applicators are
simple in their principle of operation a
fan forces a high velocity blast of air
past the nozzles the insecticide is
injected into this air blast which
breaks the liquid into fine droplets and
projects them out as a mist there are
several types of mist applicators
available some of which project to fine
aerosol spraying most of the larger
machines can be rotated in a full circle
also the nozzle can be directed from
side to side here mist is being
projected directly at fly attractants in
an alley where there are no alleys the
mist is directed in a high arc over the
houses to drift slowly down through the
insects own the speed of this downward
drift is important and is governed by
the size of the droplets if they are
large the mist will fall too rapidly a
fast rate of fall shortens the arc and
cuts down on the width of the swath
cover droplets of the proper size will
carry farther producing a wide swath and
will continue to drift downward in spite
of thermals or rising currents of warm
air on this machines droplet size is
regulated by the velocity of the air
blast the choice of nozzles and the
weight of oil use heavier oil producing
coarser droplets with fog fine droplet
size is desirable as with mist machines
several types of fog generators are
available
most of them operated from trucks
although some types are affordable
the typical thermal generator will
illustrate the principle of operation in
this machine air and gasoline are pumped
into a combustion chamber and ignited
the expanding hot gases pass through the
fog head at terrific velocity the
insecticide is introduced into the
stream of gas and is atomized into fog
contrary to the application of mist fog
is directed along the ground where it
swirls around buildings blanketing the
insect is all since fog is composed of
exceedingly fine droplets it is easily
affected by thermals and light breezes
which will quickly carry it out of the
effective area for this reason fog
should be applied at night or in early
morning or evening when the air is quiet
to measure the effectiveness of space
spray treatment it is important first to
make an appraisal of the fly population
by the grille method or of the mosquito
population by trapping continued routine
sampling during the spray program will
indicate the effectiveness of the
treatment for most effective application
the equipment should travel at about 5
miles per hour and mist directed
downwind with proper droplet size this
will produce a suave 100 feet or more in
will care must be exercised in treating
residential districts oil mist may burn
foliage and spot automobiles therefore
fog is frequently used in neighborhoods
having expensive landscaping but
remember fog is quickly carried away by
light winds and thermals which occur
during the warm part of the day
for best results bomb should be applied
during the still hours of night evening
or early morning but for photographic
purposes we are demonstrating fogging
technique by daylight in this film
commonly the city block is considered
the unit of urban space spray
however if costly insecticides must be
used then treatment of the entire block
on a citywide basis becomes too
expensive under these circumstances spot
spraying may be employed after an insect
concentration is located spray is apply
to this limited area only whether it be
a half block or a single backyard
mist machines can be used effectively
for mosquito larvae sighting directing
the mist downwind so it will carry a
sufficient distance producing a film of
lava Seidel oil on the water surface
airplane space spraying is frequently
employed for wide inaccessible areas
although airplane application is very
expensive and should be done in the
early morning or late evening hour
commercial indoor equipment is available
for use in restaurants but all food and
dishes must be covered before spraying
is begun it must be emphasized that
space spraying depends on contact and
has little or no residual effect partly
this is due to insufficient dosage as
the following demonstration will show
here mist is being applied at a normal
rate the fall of mist is picked up on a
plate of glass this operator is applying
residual insecticide to another glass
plate when both plates dry a comparison
will show the difference the dosage of
the mist is entirely inadequate for
residual effect space spraying then
depends on contact to kill insects the
effect is immediate and it is useful to
gain quick relief from flies and
mosquitoes outdoors effective kill
depends on treating the insects all
within 25 feet of the ground this may be
accomplished by applying a mist of
insecticide that drifts slowly down
through the zone or a fog that blankets
the zone and lingers close to the ground
space spraying is not a cure-all for fly
or mosquito problems it has its use for
quick relief but the results are only
temporary
however used intelligently and in
conjunction with good sanitation
practices space spraying is a useful
tool in any fly control program
[Music]